SUDDEN CATASTROPHE HIT MEXICO
CITY LATE MONDAY WHEN AN
OVERPASS COLLAPSED SENDING A
SUBWAY TRAIN PLUNGING INTO
TRAFFIC BELOW.
SECURITY VIDEO CAPTURED THE
FRIGHTENING INCIDENT.
THERE IT IS, THE OVERPASS
COLLAPSING AND TRAIN CARS
PLUNGING BELOW.
CRUSH OF HEAVY ITEMS KILLED AT
LEAST 23 PEOPLE, INCLUDING
CHILDREN.
THE MEXICO CITY MAYOR SAYS FOUR
BODIES ARE TRAPPED INSIDE THE
WRECKAGE.
DOZENS TAKEN TO HOSPITAL.
IN THE LIGHT OF DAY, WE SEE THAT
MANGLED SUBWAY CAR HANGING OFF
THE TRACKS AS CREWS DESPERATELY
WORK AND INVESTIGATORS FIGURE
OUT HOW EXACTLY THE TRAGEDY
HAPPENED.
MATT RIVERS IS THERE IN MEXICO
CITY.
MATT, GOSH, IMAGES ARE STOMACH
TURNING.
YOU SEE A TRAIN CAR BASICALLY
DANGLING FROM AN OVERPASS.
HOW DOES SOMETHING LIKE THIS
HAPPEN.
>> Reporter: ZAIN, THESE ARE
STARTLING IMAGES.
I WANT TO GIVE YOU AN IDEA WHAT
THINGS LOOK LIKE AT THE MOMENT.
WE HAVE ACCESS NEXT TO THE SCENE
HERE.
THAT LOOKS LIKE SOMETHING OUT OF
A HOLLYWOOD DISASTER MOVIE
FRANKLY, ALMOST LOOKS SURREAL.
YOU CAN JUST SEE WHAT HAPPENED
THERE.
IT IS VERY CLEAR.
THE OVERPASS COLLAPSED AND THE
SUBWAY CARS THAT WERE ON THERE
WENT DOWN WITH IT.
ONE OF THE TWO CARS HAS BEEN
REMOVED FROM THE FURTHER
SECTION, THAT INCLINE SECTION.
THE TRAIN STILL AT AN ANGLE
HANGING BETWEEN THE OVERPASS AND
THE GROUND, THAT'S OBVIOUSLY A
MORE DIFFICULT PIECE TO REMOVE.
THAT'S WHAT CREWS HAVE TO DO
NEXT.
IN TERMS OF UPDATES ON THE
LATEST OF WHAT'S HAPPENING, A
POLICE OFFICER HERE ON SCENE
SAID THERE ARE NO LONGER BODIES
THAT ARE TRAPPED INSIDE THE
RUBBLE.
THEY ALREADY REMOVED THEIR
REMAINS.
23 PEOPLE SO FAR HAVE BEEN
KILLED AS A RESULT OF THIS
INCIDENT.
NEARLY 70 PATIENTS CURRENTLY
HOSPITALS AS A RESULT OF ALL
THIS.
AND WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT HOW THAT
HAPPENED, THAT IS GOING TO BE
THE NEXT BIG QUESTION FOR
INVESTIGATORS OVER THE NEXT
DAYS, WEEKS, PROBABLY EVEN
MONTHS.
OBVIOUSLY THIS WAS A
CATASTROPHIC FAILURE IN THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THIS SUBWAY LINE WAS BUILT,
INAUGURATED IN 2012.
AS SOON AS 2014, CITY OFFICIALS
WERE DOCUMENTING STRUCTURAL
PROBLEMS ALL ALONG THIS LINE,
EVEN CLOSING MANY DIFFERENT
STATIONS THEY SAID TO ADDRESS
THE PROBLEMS.
FAST FORWARD TO 2017, MEXICO
CITY, A PLACE WHERE A LOT OF
EARTHQUAKES HAPPEN, BIG ONE IN
2017, LOTS OF DAMAGE TO THIS
LINE.
MANY PEOPLE IN THIS NEIGHBORHOOD
FEEL THE DAMAGE WAS NEVER
PROPERLY REPAIRED.
WE SPOKE TO A POLICE OFFICER
HERE WHO LIVES IN THIS
NEIGHBORHOOD.
HE TOLD US YEAH, OFFICIALS CAME
OUT, SAID EVERYTHING WAS GOOD,
BUT PEOPLE THAT LIVE IN THIS
NEIGHBORHOOD ALWAYS WONDERED IF
THERE WAS SOMETHING WRONG WITH
THIS LINE AND THERE WAS A SENSE
AMONGST PEOPLE HERE IN THIS
NEIGHBORHOOD THAT THIS WAS A
POSSIBILITY AND LOOK WHAT
HAPPENED NOW.
THE CITY GOVERNMENT, VERY AWARE
OF THE SENTIMENTS AMONG THE
POPULATION.
THEY SAY THEY'RE GOING TO LAUNCH
A FULL INVESTIGATION INTO HOW
THIS HAPPENED AND EVEN GOING TO
INVITE A YET TO BE NAMED
INTERNATIONALLY RESPECTED AS
THEY PUT IT OUTSIDE FIRM TO
ESSENTIALLY DO AN AUDIT ON THE
LINE TO SEE WHAT, IF OTHER,
SAFETY ISSUES THERE MIGHT BE.
ZAIN, THAT'S THE KIND OF THING
GIVEN THE CONCERNS THROUGHOUT
THE TENURE OF THE LINE HERE,
KIND OF CONCERN YOU WOULD HAVE
THINK WOULD BE ADDRESSED YEARS
AGO.
>> EXACTLY RIGHT.
THAT'S WHY FAMILY MEMBERS OF T